we are live I believe this is happening
over any stick around stick around
Letterman is going to jiu-jitsu what
I'll beat you Jitsu yeah we are live
ladies and gentlemen the lovely voices
that you're seeing are Louis J Gomez
don't forget the Jag you don't see
without you getting your teeth chipped
away you see it on this one and then of
course a woman that's just learned a
very valuable lesson and we talked about
this on punch and all all the time you
want to teach a woman a lesson you teach
it with your goddamn fists and teeth and
ha ha ha and would you guys get a
life-sized replica of my dick I don't
know well Amy Letterman just decided to
throw that down I believe that's our
co-host on her pocket Kim Condon
everybody what's up just shot
congratulations your HBO thing for HBO
yeah thank you shot that we're in Texas
somewhere right yes an Antonio it was
cool they put us up at a haunted hotel
which is a weird move to do I mean how
do you know was haunted was a rumor you
actually had it well the first night I
didn't know was haunted I slept with the
lights on for no reason and I then the
next morning I came out to meet everyone
I made a joke about it I was like last
night I was so scared I slept with the
lights on they're like that's what I
wonder where she's taking that I see
what happens when you're Puerto Rican
and you don't have lights when you're a
kid now when you have the opportunity
this is too much amazing you have no
electricity so then when you finally do
you're just like leave everything on the
blenders going for the microwave just
put 47 minutes use your microwave as an
alarm clock exactly you don't believe in
a ghost and the same thing happened to
me about like a year ago I got third
voice that you were seeing Gabe Killian
everybody hey Gabe the banker yes I see
though I actually yeah ten minutes in
[ __ ] are we really live
are you actually live yeah nobody what's
going on is always welcome alive on
narrow-mouthed just call see if we have
available we're live on
on myspace Jake oh man by the way do you
know that your [ __ ] girlfriend and by
the way we want to get to you teaching a
lesson because this is something we
always say on punch uh-huh
which is these women got it no they got
a life if you got a bleed for the face
with my hand we say it all the time all
the time Kim's got a I'm happy for you
oh thank you so much Ellen oh I just
released an hour that I came on
specifically to promote no games [ __ ] in
15 minutes so gia latina as [ __ ]
overshadowed everything cool guys no big
deal she's old G from back in the day
let's talk about because I really loved
what you did Lewis J Gomez presents Lucy
a goat as you went down the arm the same
room I went but you're a much better
businessman than me
I like your promotions and all that you
know I have number respect for your game
well I watch what you did with your
special which was incredible and I took
a lot of influence and and I've learned
what not to do let us not forget
punching all-star gogo over here yes
last time you're here we had an
explosion and started a fire my newsroom
has loose J Gomez his podcast you and
Mike it was Mickey gall yeah they
weren't happy because you were [ __ ]
goddamn Clipper hat
well the Laker hat I was gonna that's
why we've wanted you I wanted to I was
going on the road a lot I was gonna buy
a black you I'm gonna buy a black on
black fitted for every city I go to
whatever the team is but not Lakers I
have no idea I don't know I love that
your own sports podcast you still I had
no idea if that was all here to do
research not you know yeah it was a
black on black Laker hat and they hate
the Lakers I freaked out on me and I'm
on an anti Laker podcast we're in a
Laker hat yeah I mean they said will you
and the story is I'm a problem and I
said you are they paid me to like this
hat on fire now sure we didn't have to
throw lighters into the fire and make an
explosion yeah I got mad magic Oh calls
me like the next day what you guys are
making explosions
why do you don't even have to just go to
the back of bets we're definitely the
black sheep of this this podcast network
anytime there are two people that call
me I'm like when the phone rings and I
love both these people very much Pokemon
my friend rings I go god damn it and it
cuz means someone's in trouble it's your
girlfriend Dana yeah and al Madrigal
yeah those two people are calling me I'm
like oh I gotta take I'll be right back
I gotta go have you guys done dates how
the gates hey Gabe you got some gate
dates coming up I'll be at the chicken
hut other Wednesday the banker
Ottawa May 1st 2nd and 3rd a Yuk Yuk's
comedy club Montreal May 11th at Peroni
resto bar 9 p.m. Toronto Mayor May 14 15
16 and 17 time I Yuk Yuk's I like how
you say 16 its how immigrants talk yeah
what does that acts I don't even know
what it is hanging dog Hollywood
Armenian Hollywood r-mo a little bit of
East Hollywood illiterate the tiny - of
illiterate so you're playing all these
is this a solo tour yeah in Rochester on
may 19th at the comedy club at the bug
jar okay look at you dude that's great
man
that's great oh you guys yeah bug jar
he's gonna be yeah oh great that's so
great ah do you got any gets any dates
dates up the gate yeah boy May 1st I'll
be down the shore uncle Vinny's comedy
club just one night only and then yeah I
mean I got some stuff coming up but the
most important thing guys skank fest NYC
is coming up June 21st ago why is why is
punch-drunk been blind
bald from this fast-developing
blackballed from the festival if you're
all gonna be there I already told you
guys you guys can DuPont drunk at the
festival there's no doubt about it
all right so we're all gonna be there
all right yeah I mean so it's gonna be
Jason Ari's gonna be there me and we'll
figure out everything else that's it you
guys'll be asking fest there's no doubt
about it literally the only thing I said
you guys was yeah if you're gonna be
there of course we'll do a pond shrunk
why wouldn't we is this how you guys
book it's crazy crazy
tickets are basically sold out I think
you can get like maybe a couple tickets
for Friday man all-access pass because
it's two months out now infinity beauty
is one of our sponsors which there's an
incredible company best CBD in the world
but they're sponsoring skank festered
the marquee sponsor if you follow
infinity BD on any social media they're
gonna be posting ways we can get free
all-access passes giving me doing get
all these things like that so I've sort
of God and a lot of our fans went to it
last year yeah if you didn't it's the
[ __ ] the one of the funnest festivals to
get is well as a phantom prime it's not
not much fun yeah you and I pretty much
hung out with you the most yeah we had
so much [ __ ] class really would you
guys do everybody was on acid everybody
that's what we should just call it
everybody's on acid acid acid and
mushrooms yes you were singing on stage
when I just thought when I just crowd
surfed I just walked up and just jumped
into the crowd because you dared me to
do it yeah you and [ __ ] so much fun
it is it's one venue like everybody are
you singing and what do you think I
don't know I'm thinking about doing Pat
Benatar
I love that I'm not eating what I want
what's up what's up the desert some
girls have about like how good they're
at taking punches I can say hey he also
stopped making the joke that I actually
punched hurricane I tell the [ __ ]
story tell us we're getting into it you
always gonna keep on teasing it for the
whole show podcast we teach they stay
longer still that what's up dates out
the gates where are you gonna be god
this
coming up um yeah uh follow me on
Twitter at Kim Kannan falling me on
instagram at Kim really calmed in
actually those are reverse Oh check out
my podcast broad topics iTunes Google
Play YouTube that's topics t OPI x check
out my other podcast subway creatures on
the gas digital network and I have a web
series that just came out it's called
stone science where I get comedians hi
and we do a science fair project
together and you can find that that must
be huge I was like you know what do
better with your science oh really oh
you think that's a volcano I'll show you
I'll show you something gushing there's
some baking soda on that [ __ ] this
Tuesday coming not tonight but this
following Tuesday April 30th absolute
extract presents comedy chaos 2 shows a
p.m. show and a 10:30 show and the first
show we got Christina paczynski orny
Adams Steve Rannazzisi Eddie Bravo and
Tony Rock second show is at 10:30 doors
open at 10:00 p.m.
show 10:30 we got preacher Lawson Eddie
Bravo jessimae Peluso Bobby Lee and
myself and more people to come so that
is that and that's all I feel like
promoting today I am lazy I got a couple
things I'm promoting I'm gonna be at
Moose knuckles on Christmas morning for
their big feed the homeless then kick
them out door breakfast guess which side
of the counter and I'll be on I hope
it's delicious then I'm playing dubstep
on a tuba every 6 Monday of each month
over adjacent to the Hollywood Bowl
that's pretty prestigious then I'm
judging the day I'm judging the big
facepunch facepunch at the why didn't
you go [ __ ] yourself festival in New
Jersey last July is the master
ceremonies well we'll talk about that
let's get into this this because a lot
of people have been talking to so you
guys at the store last night
and the word across the street is even
just literally beating the [ __ ] out of
this idiot feisty what's going on and
with our ice meat pie they meant when
they wrote battled each other right yeah
well we met on Brian Webb band's podcast
years ago oh sorry that was the first
time we ever like chatted or hung out or
whatever and then we knew each other
casually and then yes she challenged me
to a roast battle when I was coming out
to LA with some of the battlers it was
the first time you guys [ __ ] did you
guys [ __ ] before after you battle ah
that's a great question no we [ __ ]
after the battle that night who was
because I know I think she would have
fought in a feud walk away I've been
really good friends over for a long time
I'll consider your very very good friend
sue telling me from before that she's
like I'm gonna give me some of that my
life she didn't say that yes absolutely
in my line I would never talk like that
I in your own words one time let me tell
you Sam is such a hater I've ever met
why dude he's just a piece of [ __ ] he's
literally doing a flyer for other pop on
the podcast right now also you
exaggerate we don't need no enjoyment we
were time of you Sam brought me on the
road assuming that I [ __ ] headliners
because I said comment and then I didn't
[ __ ] him and I was flirting people
tomorrow then he came back on the
podcast he was like Kim common flirting
with people at the bar Jimmy Caan be
careful yeah bro I brought up a good boy
24 years old I've gone out before her
pointed that was a guy you'd be like
have fun getting [ __ ] yeah you and he's
like that's why he was so concerned
you know Sam oh by the way the reason I
Pasha was this story a marine - you've
been down to PB like late night after
shell right I woke up in the beach there
right and it's just like circling solid
21 year old drunk military right and I'm
an old [ __ ] man right I just want to
get my tacos go back to the [ __ ]
condo in [ __ ] my destroy everybody
that [ __ ] moves right
she just throwing game and everybody
mucking it up
flirting working can I tell you I don't
have to muck it up and throw I don't
have to [ __ ] throw cloudy I don't
know how to my drunken military man what
I said is exactly the issue he thought
that I [ __ ] I would [ __ ] and I did it
and then he was like why is she lying
that's one chick I've ever brought down
that I tried to bang yeah that debate
was tried can we tell the story why I
punch her because I think he's it for
know I'm sounding like I actually
punched her it's starting to make me I
saw her maybe 45 minutes for I saw you
last night yeah I was sitting in a
crying Baker ground and then yeah she
was just like you know when you're in a
shower and he's like there's like a rape
it was like you behaved rocky v when
she'd just been beaten to a living pulp
no and we saw an ID you and you had to
your friends that were with you some
blonde had a girl - yeah white girls
very white girls example all hot white
chicks it's great that blonde was pretty
cute anyway but your tongue I'm your I'm
your welcome both of them to like flip a
coin yeah and then you were like I don't
walked in the store and you're like
I know who hit you because if anybody
Wow
so anyways what's your version because
we were flat boxing play fighting
whatever you do we did kill Tony at the
Policy Center Mall oh no wonder you
punch her yeah and no but like we yeah
we had a uh you know we had a great time
which getting hammered drinking whiskey
the whole night whatever she's drinking
vodka yeah afterwards we ended up going
to Dave & Buster's okay and we're just
always a mistake yeah what are you even
doing he's not even on Mike he's just in
a computer comics on this show lovely
giving you your chance to talk last week
turn no comics I'm sure I need just in
the middle of a sentence he just does
this this shows great what happened it's
a great show it is a great show and I'm
listening to you go on Jesus Christ so
we need to [ __ ] focus are you this
job that is so funny leave them out
there you want to run the show do you
want finally your time to talk we got
game get in the seat no no what if Dave
just leaves - hey are all your friends
leaving New York to come to LA now it
seems like a lot of people are gonna
just Tim I did if you were gay when you
move that light this is like Mecca yeah
maybe you know I mean it's New York
yeah he's love that bumper New York's
pretty good can't wait the Khufu's out
especially a guy because you're a little
less judgmental in New York yeah you
know in LA if you're in West Hollywood
Tim's not necessarily eyes into that
[ __ ] you know couple things not gonna
say names about we're into we know a
couple dudes are like some big fat it's
going to fun all right here's where
the names I say alright so then you're
cute wait because I got locked out you
just threw your curb-stomp in this chair
like bite the car [ __ ] [ __ ] curb
know so we because what happens we're
Puerto Rican and we were raised as
garbage Dave & Buster's
so what Dave & Buster's and we get drunk
so we start to play around usually it
just starts off with like you know like
she gets into a fight stance and then I
get into fights and we said slapbox them
a little bit then she'll throw a leg
kick on land and I'll check make that
just sound like a normal relationship
you know we reach a fight regularly and
especially when we're drunk it's just
sort of a fun thing so [ __ ] Latin
thing I've known both of you for a while
and I would describe both hotheads it's
how we mate fighting for slapbox and
it's just it's starting to get like kind
of sexy because you both want to win I'm
getting turned on I also want the belt
but I'll pull it I won't you know we
should probably keep it out I'll check
it and show her - [ __ ] chin on my leg
but she's going hard like that's how she
hurt her face on your face
boring every you go to [ __ ] a gym -
chick fighters go full blast you guys
like pat pat yes girls are trying to
fight for their supper
oh we can avoid by the way we can slap
bucks in the genre I'll show you I will
wreck her [ __ ] can't leave anything but
she's really trying so she doesn't have
any [ __ ] control of her dumb body so
I'm just pumping the jab I'm being I'm
just having fun dude literally she walks
into the gym you walked in there hey
stop walking him down there's one thing
we always say on his podcast stop
walking
I never said that have you have you but
you know a lot you look like
I threw a jab out just a little [ __ ]
just to measure the distance she walks
right into it it hits her right here
that's what happened your nose okay
[Applause]
so the by the way the whole time a
manager he's on the phone and security
like trying to get us a stop and he's
mortified he just doesn't even
understand cuz it looks sort of real
from history should I guess because
Kim's really [ __ ] getting into it and
as she look we're both at this point is
sadly crying laughing we're like just so
dry that's why she was like blood
calling our teeth it was hot that's hot
the important thing is she learned her
lesson yeah walk away from the jab who
do you think wins in the fight Kim or
game you gotta put money on it gave the
banker second I would rock games I would
watch that game how much you weigh okay
but who do you think would win in a
fight me or game
I don't know well here's me he's got
that what does that sound you hear that
yeah it's not real do you hear it's not
really you away anything are you awake
right now
no somebody hit a off its our down there
you don't hear not okay that's all
matters don't worry about it okay all
right sure cuz it stills like zing zing
zing zing zing zing yeah
so should we oh there we go nope nope
nope nope
this is Lucien Gomez producer coming in
right here
I guess we're fine eh oh man where can
they find your special eye Louis Shaco
must possess the wishing almost not calm
you get it like your links for iTunes
Google all that you can buy it directly
there as well are you super happy with
it yeah dude I'm really pumped it's it's
hard do you know did you edit something
you're gonna watch it over and over
again the problem is by the you know ten
twelve fifteen time you're watching now
you're pulling things out cuz you're
starting to notice things you didn't
notice before yeah so you have to step
away from it sometimes got to yeah we
shot two shows and yeah it was [ __ ]
great dude it was really fun it's
addictive right yeah cuz you're like
[ __ ] I want to do this again I know yeah
you know and now I just started kind of
getting back and writing new material
now so but you're people like it if you
like really [ __ ] up material you'll
like this it's [ __ ]
dirty it's not like [ __ ] you're getting
on Netflix your comedy yeah exactly it's
very you know and whatever dude if you
[ __ ] just appreciate guys who are
doing [ __ ] on their own buy it and
[ __ ] give it away to somebody else
that you know likes dirty comedy you
know you put together like a show where
we shoot like four guys who are just
super dark yeah what we're doing
something like that we're doing we're
doing a series we have a sponsor that's
coming in we're gonna be shooting
probably 10 or 12 guys it's all like
edgier all like we're looking to do
someone I submit a video hundred percent
come on baby boy Wow
below you come back for weeks we see how
you do can I help before you on the 16
so yeah I mean look you depending on how
my head you get into a lot of fistfights
and not lately when's the last time we
were in a fight that's sixteenth it's
over a decade over a decade yeah how big
was she yeah did you win I only because
she was pregnant I think I won yeah
this practice I jumped into a gang yeah
it's [ __ ] great yeah I mean dude ones
last time you guys were in a street
fight no no way official finish so real
you check her with a you know your
region he hits me I am bleeding and
laughing and we're both laughing in that
and then we just walk away and this
guy's just staring like security cave no
before that happened now we were like
let's run yeah this is we get into
things publicly a lot I bet we've been
to things in airports you murder check
oh my god what do you guys do I throw
for did you throw her phone the girl
that spit at you yeah wait it wasn't
with you it seems like a decent guy it
wasn't it wasn't us here's what I just
heard
but wait hey babe remember we got into
that thing at the airport well when you
do that girl's phone no no the one that
spit on us that's the same time well
there's been a couple Airport things but
this was the one that's no no this girl
spit at you and it was [ __ ] up because
just bit Louis and Louis spit back but
when she spit at Louis nobody was there
and as soon as he spit back at her
people were corner yeah it was [ __ ] up
mother's black chick she was uh black so
you know yeah we heard I love black
chicks now you don't want them like ton
of milk in the coffee or like deep space
black like no light nothing like just
[ __ ] deep I want Blake Griffen kids
that's what I'm looking for since
midnight yeah dark deep spanis um no Kim
was getting off the flight and she was a
couple seats ahead of the girl that was
behind her right and I guess Kim because
there was no room in her above her head
she had to put her bag back so as people
are getting off the way if your plan is
people get off ahead of you except if
you're Asian they just shoot the line
have you ever know it's lost you can
learn sometimes so I pretend I got to
get a connecting flight you could just
pretend connecting flight run-through
sorry I oh this is really [ __ ] up I am
I go I yeah did you murder somebody guy
or D and I go right behind the disabled
people I make sure I'm the last and the
disabled so that I'm just technically I
got a whole other way I got a wheelchair
to everything yeah but I don't like to
ask yeah I go the last disabled I go
after the last disabled person and
before first class you do you fake a
clubfoot or something like now you're
putting a little bit weird ask me I will
be miss Delta I'll change my name to
Delta I'll see them yeah but yeah this
at this girl she wants to get her bag
and this girl I guess was behind her she
was like well sorry you gotta wait until
I get off the plane you know until
everyone gets off so the Kim and her
sort of arguing I guess right I went to
can't believe people were just kept are
believed to so what I said was I was
like can I just grab my bag so I have to
wait for the whole plane to get off cuz
I was in the front why don't they just
hand you your bag that's what I was
trying to do but nobody did it so I was
like let me grab it so as I was grabbing
it
I heard her say you should have put your
shoes sing in the seat and she's like
you should have put your bag at the next
to your seat and then I said I would
have done that but it was full and she
goes what type of person is this angry
white chick old watch a black chick okay
thank you for tuning in
probably her first time flying and then
she and then she I was like it was full
so I couldn't and then she was like well
then you should have gotten a different
seat oh [ __ ] now it's a Puerto Rican
girl black girl white people are nervous
Porto Rican yeah yeah and then I just
said I said whatever [ __ ] whoa she's
being a [ __ ] she just have to say
nothing and now everybody on the plane
she made it a thing and then she's like
your mom's a [ __ ] and I didn't even say
anything I just walked out she is hot
didn't I hit on your mom now but now we
have a black woman Hills character yeah
so now she's pissed so I grab my [ __ ]
and Luis is waiting for me right like
when you get off the plane we're not
sitting next to each other which is the
best I love when we don't have to sit
next to each other cuz she will [ __ ]
lean on me yeah yeah think it's hot
after your [ __ ]
she wanted I wanted to be able to just
[ __ ] browse the Internet do what I do
right yeah so I get off and Lewis is not
like in the airport yet he's in like
that area where you're like getting on
to the plane that like waiting for me
there and I catch up and he can tell
that I'm pissed he's like what I was
like nothing some [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
and like I'm Joe we're just getting our
[ __ ] together are you warming up at this
point no no no I'm kind of like I saw
her face and I was like you want to go I
imagine I imagine Gomez like on a plane
like it's just constantly but one of
those stones just sharpening a knife
like no reason just in case and and then
she gets off the plane she's passing us
how old is this person how did you know
they're black black peoples by their
hands that's okay
24 to about 84 okay yeah so uh so then
she walks by and she mumbles something
else she was a mumble wrapper is that
dad yeah by the way and at this point I
had told Louis's someone infected me so
as soon as she mumbled something Luis
went what like would you say you know
keep your girl shut whatever and then
they start arguing and cuz now you
caught up to her she's not I caught up
to him so shoulder booked you she walked
by yeah yeah that's what it was she kind
of like aggressively walked by and she
bumped her she gave her a little [ __ ]
bumper oh to let you know yeah high
school a little shoulder and I'm a
[ __ ] high school kid at heart so I
saw that and I recognized that and I
just sort of get defensive of my people
and I get between them and I'm like what
are you [ __ ] doing so she starts
cursing at me and then they start
arguing like threw us back and forth so
I'm like beat it you [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] whatever and then she spits at me
and then I spits up she spits on me
that's that's like slapping them to me
yeah I'm almost positive than almost any
state a little you could get arrested
it's a salty mosted so it is a salt so
that I'm sorted
I spit back in her that's when people
come by time and as soon as spits back
at her people are coming around the
corner but sure you can hear them being
like oh my god and I was like oh [ __ ]
right and then she pulls out her cell
phone she starts filming she's like you
don't know who I am you're gonna be on
TMZ and it was gonna be empty so turns
out it was Rihanna she was gonna call
TMZ and I was like we're both in coach
like I don't know yeah II was pretending
that she was famous yes it was crazy
it was crazy so then Kim just takes her
phone was she hot at all hot it was look
when she was piled by one to ten she
wasn't wearing weaves at that moment she
wasn't you know she was wearing travel
travel dog but so listen this chick
though she's got a cell phone out it was
just couldn't weird moment of like she's
like you don't know what's going on
and Kim takes her phone that over and
just takes it oh my god would you
strong-arm robbery
watch me fast we found out they're Conor
McGregor strong-arm robbery Kim's from
Rob's this girl and then it was just
silent for some reason to everyone went
silent and at this point the flight
attendants are holding it everyone's
watching like this are hip-hop so it was
a moment where when Kim throws the phone
down split down the hallway the first
everyone's faces just watched it and
everything went silent and we started
screen as it hit the metal thing anyway
come on broke into pieces
the back probably just came off she was
screaming she was trying to get through
she was trying to hit me she was
stepping on her own dog she had a dog
with her and she was like stepping on an
inch it and then we just left we did
some secret did our coats off they try
to detain us yeah they try to detain us
the the flight attendants and they're
like you gotta wait for the cops come on
we're doing
in Kota we switch we switch hats it was
[ __ ] crazy that's so dumb
every time we woke up to be another
people watching I swear to god we hopped
into different cans
it was [ __ ] nuts dude wait so all
this is on that little tarmac thing that
we don't even really start it she
started it she's spinning she sure did
sang [ __ ] she was just a [ __ ] she
popped the wrong people sounds like
she's got one wrong day [ __ ] wrong day
[ __ ] hey philos black [ __ ] about the
guy that made the plane land early was
that guy you
Louis J hold on there's another instance
no no this wasn't it we have a guy
that's a fan who he if I just tell him
my flights he makes the planes Lander he
makes our planes Linda really like 30
minutes good it's great what you're
saying I don't know if we should be
saying it I know it there's no way
that's why he's definitely listen no way
it's legal that he's allowed to clear
the [ __ ] runways for louis gomez
whenever I'm flying that's [ __ ] but
okay so we met him and I didn't believe
it and he was like he was like he'll get
your flights really the next day very
much so Peter the next day we had two
separate flights and that guy said the
night before I'll hook it up and I was
like no way and when I land it or when
we were landing the pilot was like hey
we'll be landing thirty minutes early
today and I was like that's [ __ ]
weird my flight landed early I called
Lewis he's like my flight just landed 30
minutes early too and this guy had been
night before told us he would hammer
that was money the kid I'm gonna don't
worry I got I got a watch number your
flight number what does he do besides he
works for the [ __ ] airline like clear
traffic yeah so he can just make her how
many times has he done this just it was
just that once I asked me but he said
at any time I know just in it's like
wherever you're flying that's a good
yeah I know but I just feel like it's
definitely not safe how many people how
many people are in charge of [ __ ]
air-traffic control how many employees
are there why did I meet a drunk one bad
but they all drink they drink like I
said everyone the most stressful job
does everyone have their own air traffic
control team at every Airport I have no
idea how it works it could be a hundred
people in a building somewhere or it
could be five people and every Airport I
have no idea what their infrastructure
is no I think those things have like in
each airline I think there's like maybe
like a thousand people and we have other
buddy used to do that stuff and I think
he actually made two planes crash just
for now yeah he was a good he was not a
man of a different [ __ ] podcasting
comment can he's like I am gonna make
your plane crash at thirty minutes early
there's a really good document
documenting about air traffic control
it's called die hard - that's very good
that was great - thanks for piping in so
he was supposed to be on my other
podcast and he was gonna get the guy
from Fox what's that movie Foxcatcher
Foxcatcher the wrestler was gonna come
on and talk about [ __ ] root canal and
then they [ __ ] spaced no root canal
leads to like cancer and heart disease
yeah I heard that
no yeah if you get a root canal yeah
yeah nobody gets heart disease that
hasn't had a root canal is theirs that's
like the correlation well yeah you
people don't get heart disease without
have I believe something like that right
apparently all your teeth are connected
to like body parts and organs and stuff
and when you get a root canal is pretty
much a dead tooth and what it does it
sounds like releases toxins in your body
through this [ __ ] shitty rotten tooth
yeah what about your teeth knocked out
and get veneers put a lot of Kim's teeth
are connected to your knuckles
how many people are here how long have
you been gone we've been asking for you
I am I'm getting one in a few days what
are you going Gold do what happened I
just I had a blue meth have a heart
attack what nothing
you're fine Gomez you are like me you
get a lot of internet fights no no I
don't yeah I see a lot of Twitter you
going at people it's not a fight it's
one-sided more than me versus a camera I
love what you do man I'm you and I like
to fight the good fight I sure like just
to protect the art I feel like the art
needs to be protected and there's these
[ __ ] business guys who just want to
sell it out as quickly as I can for a
[ __ ] dollar when was the last fight I
mean like I always say you fight with
some they're always trying to come at
you here's what happens I whenever I
travel I am very bored and I have a lot
of downtime so I end up engaging with
people whether they're comics internet
trolls whatever it is it's just because
I'm bored and I kind of want to have fun
but I'm too busy in life to like even I
usually after I do it I just delete the
entire interaction because I'm like all
right I had fun that was it I don't need
to you know yeah I've left Facebook for
that reason was getting into dumb
arguments with people on Facebook off
it's so you know it's so it's so [ __ ]
boring but yeah I'm not I will not I
will engage in a little back and forth
in a little battle it's also part of our
brands and sort of who we are and what
we do it's like yeah you know I get into
it a lot on Grindr [ __ ] [ __ ] who
you talk to gorgeous next thing you know
[Laughter]
it's comics that do it I that upsets me
other comics when other comics think
there should be rules on Cosmo that's
the absolute worst I I mean I have this
one chick comic on TV talk I don't know
if they're naming or she blocked me on
social media and you're like that's you
hear that Sarah Silverman yeah it was uh
but it's like I mean guys come on we're
all just fighting the good fight here I
I feel like I have a kinship with every
comic you know as soon as as soon as you
get up on stage I'm like I just kind of
we're in a club together and I you know
yeah whether even if you're a horse [ __ ]
[ __ ] feminists [ __ ] whatever do
your thing you know I don't really give
a [ __ ] you know even that whole [ __ ]
the net [ __ ] nobody would have given a
[ __ ] a better horse [ __ ] special if she
didn't come out and start attacking real
comics and saying like oh well you know
these guys shouldn't even be able to do
comedy and you know it was sort of like
a reaction to these interviews that she
did where she was just attacking you
know was it was mainly men but it was
yeah straight white males when you know
it's dog [ __ ] they've come up with like
Captain Marvel that movie tanked and
they knew it's gonna tank so what they
did is they came out with this like this
is a feminist movie to try to get all
the [ __ ] floors really excited about
it right all the chunky fours and that's
what they do they they make it they try
to make it so if it doesn't do well it's
because of sexism and not the fact that
they put out some dogs well remember
when they did they reorganized the the
metrics for Ron tomatoes because I guess
they want to say that it was right
before they said the number one like
rated film on Rotten Tomatoes of all
time number one superhero film was
what's her name captain no no wonder
what Bob but it wasn't she didn't
actually ha she didn't have the actual
highest rating it was another movie that
had the highest rating but they Reeve
configured the way the number one 100%
it was a real thing they legitimately
did that because there's more marketing
and saying like look the number one
superhero movie of all time is with a
woman but at the same time we don't need
to get caught up in being you know I
surprised me when white guys are like
well why can I have a B team we can't
have a WT it's like it's just sort of
like alright so let him [ __ ] have it
who gives a [ __ ] right let's go create
our own yeah it's like fine the reality
is Wonder Woman was it was a great movie
it really was and that's a little I
liked it Batman Dark Knight Oh imagine
she was sitting in a room you couldn't
even yeah looking order you know one
time I was and this is how hot she must
be because one time I was at a house and
just randomly doing stand-up in a weird
night sounds kind of no back
day and Penelope Cruz was there with
Javier Bardem they're just sitting Oh
Santa Javier Bardem is that but they're
sitting there just having coffee and
they like I'm talking like sweatpants
and t-shirts kind of dressed and she was
so goddamn beautiful in person yeah and
she's not even a star that you would be
like wow she's like a top three yeah I'm
not even I saw had me either
but you see her in person you're like
you would be like goddamn she has to be
somebody yeah
she was that [ __ ] beautiful so like
you're saying if that Wonder Woman chick
was here right now you'd be like all of
us would be you punch yourself in the
face again I probably feel the same way
so let me a terminating me hot I
remember working at at the standard and
Kobe Bryant came in and like at this
time Kobe Bryant was like chisel like
everything you're like that's a
good-looking guy that dude shredded he's
got to be something if you didn't know
it my girlfriend mother [ __ ] that dude I
couldn't get mad at him really I
couldn't get mad at him does I'd be like
okay dude I get it take a shot the title
I would specifically get mad at like
this giant black guy really yeah I do
die that's how good-looking you I might
go for I get it I get it but I don't
think a woman could go the other that's
in Kobe had hair oh babe could you go
the other way like alright let's just
all right he's saying that like oh like
the girls so hot that I'm like Iggy like
wonder what a woman says I want to [ __ ]
Lou would you be like alright I have to
give you this pass because it's it's
Wonder Woman would you would you be she
was sitting where Gabe is and she was
like hey on the 16th I'm gonna suck his
dick I would just leave because no
matter what I said you're probably gonna
[ __ ] Wonder Woman well she asked and
then he says no then she's really gonna
want to [ __ ] on and then you're awesome
yeah well then he's gonna be mad at me
she's gonna be wanting to [ __ ] him it's
gonna be a whole thing between them I'm
telling it's [ __ ] right now Kim
would start beating the [ __ ] out of
wonderful
we just [ __ ] up Wonder Woman and I'm the
same way there's no way like I'm just
too jealous of a guy where if it was
like talked about like celebrity passes
and it's just no she's not happening
yeah you both agreed uh uh because it's
not that like number one you're both
yeah you're both jealous people also
like we're comedians and like P Warren
[ __ ] ariana grande so anything could
happen
yeah [ __ ] anybody that has a punch line
apparently no I like Matt right I think
funny line Tripoli's like you think
she's hot top way to go out no with him
on that one did she like she's my
daughter
no how'll she plan her 20s she's like 13
if Lewis likes or that I mean that I
don't give a [ __ ] Johnny look up her
daughter Oh is she 20 maybe 21 she and
Ashley [ __ ] up one of these uh hooker up
one of her videos really converse hurt a
friend she's being hot in their panties
Oh Sam what do you want me to [ __ ]
say here good girl she's details don't
want you to talk slower bro she's so hot
it's College these celebrities now have
crazy hot daughters two dozen the USC
singer [ __ ] Betty's daughter are you
kidding it's retort of your [ __ ] dumpster
dog problem I'm gonna probably either
good for them would if I was that hot I
would just be like yeah I'm gonna be
rich and suck dick he'll be like why
pain suck some dicks live on a yacht be
hard I get to wake up at 2:00 in the
afternoon a party later behind me into a
college but College what's that cool
it's great like it's awesome sucking
dick if you're a chick is probably
pretty dope like if you're into it right
like him it's not about you in disguise
eating [ __ ]
I love you
I mean most chicks I feel like the days
they're not big dick sucker no I think
Church who are intersex already sucking
dick I feel like they want their [ __ ]
eaten and then they're just gonna lay
there the last quarter yeah they're like
lick my [ __ ] I'll let you [ __ ] me but I
think you like my dick you down with all
that if people are sexual if you don't
want to suck a strange dick yeah a lot
and community in the butt what do you
mean are you guys big Buster's weird
thing with like branches ah it's it's
like I don't think I think a lot of
girls don't suck dick because they don't
just want to be sucking because they
know guys and they don't wanna be
sucking dick
yeah we do dumb [ __ ] oh yeah you [ __ ]
just had a mousetrap on it or something
oh yeah it's all kinds of weird [ __ ] all
kinds of rich yeah but no like yeah I I
watched a raccoon with my dick the other
day if I was a chick I would I think I'd
be a pretty big dick sucker I'm not
gonna lie I have a special feeling you
could suck a mean dick we'll be right
back what does a mean dick it's like I
got six inches of dynamite I've been
measuring it since I was a kid I think
that's more like an m-80 really it's
dynamo dude what if it's a the
firecrackers that what you're saying
I'm fine with that out sound it i Scout
find a chick who doesn't have a car
trunk for a [ __ ] that's my thing haha
like that snatch good luck with that
yeah all right it's been a great show
guys we'll be right back right after
this
oh yeah how long you guys in town for
tomorrow right yeah we are tomorrow
and you were in town looking for new
studios and we're doing some stuff we're
doing actually on a break right now
no started yet it happened
we actually don't have you warmed up for
two hours then we do a five five people
are here to talk we actually don't have
a podcast Sam Tripoli died two years ago
simulation this is my hologram he's a
ghost
they are doing hologram now comedy have
you seen that I have seen like bad
enough we got YouTube stars taking our
[ __ ] thing now we're gonna have an
hologram yeah dude they're trying to do
like Carlin [ __ ]
we're trying to do all Rodney
Dangerfield's don't you go see him do
like their spit you know they're old
special no or there they're gonna get
people can write in there no there's
style like Rodney Dangerfield you could
write in their style I don't know if you
can do George Carlin that's
disrespectful
I heard Tupac's hologram is now doing
spots yeah no I heard that they're
actually doing music like years ago
chela they did a two-pump that's where
it started and now it's getting out of
here it was pretty crazy when they did
it but they never really they haven't I
haven't seen anything else since I saw
his Tupac's hologram was doing spots at
The Improv the other night some like now
he's doing comedy like this is taraf he
was selling t-shirts of the comics today
no that was whatever that homeless boom
Shakalaka
people be saying things you guys do kill
Tony last night it was supposed to but
you didn't know ensures me you were
doing it then I was gonna know I was
gonna show up at the end and put my name
in the bucket and go out and do a new
minute I did it as Tony once and then it
one [ __ ] net I don't want them judge
I have like red band jessiemae Peluso
[ __ ] on my comedy jessimae Peluso
she's awesome I love red banshees why'd
you say it like that like you don't like
red band I do love red band he could
show up at any minute actually he might
show up he might not show right Liam
[ __ ] nice what's your favorite
podcasts to do punch obviously [ __ ]
gets it gets it clearly gets you talk to
Mickey lately yeah yeah I'm into the
skanks right after he brought that pro
wrestler Enzo on we had a really fun
Allegiance ganks with him positive
attitude about the whole loss and you
know it is what it is hey man that's
just gonna be that sport yeah like
there's not gonna be somebody that's
just completely undefeated goes for do
you know like a Mayweather which you
know because you can't dump people in
the UFC the promise he also
they brought him on so fast he got these
high high-profile fights and once you
sort of turn that corner
yeah right you can't go back right you
can't start taking the heat you know
using he only had a handful of fights
very very few fights is still under my
hand few was us six fights not even I
five maybe five so babe how many fights
hey mickey yeah in the UFC your outside
oh oh yeah total both [ __ ] that's
your boss that thing's got five ya know
it's like I think he was 5 and 1 now
he's 5 and 2 I think and it's fine dude
yes 5 wins no let's look it up why don't
I look it up it's fine dude if you do
that I I just feel like they did push
him and even like Anderson Silva when he
finally got to the UFC he'd fought in
all these other organizations fight we
had a couple losses when he came in no
didn't know Anderson Silva yeah [ __ ]
set the world on fire when he came hold
on no not what I'm saying
I'm saying his record when he called
right yes yes he had a couple losses yes
and it's okay devil I'd like the UFC
it's almost but they were also horseshit
losses like honkin Aarohi I think got
caught or it was maybe a
disqualification one of the voices they
were it was like one one of them was one
hitting downward over down oh yeah yeah
you need a phone or something so but
here you're right he wasn't undefeated
it's just not gonna happen for the most
part John Jones is the closest thing to
high-level undefeated it could be
because undefeated legitimately a
[ __ ] him but um II will say I mean
you know these guys once you're there at
the top of the food chain in the UFC the
top four or five guys in every [ __ ]
weight class are murderers there and
it's almost like any given Sunday
there's so many ways you can lose in
that sport that it's like it's gonna
happen
Mickey was just sort of a victim of he
got that high-profile fight he's not
gonna have any and you know people to
get put on the map by beating almost a
tomato can that had a big name yes
so now he's and he isn't getting any of
those [ __ ] fights with guys that are
coming up in the UFC kind of coming into
his own he's getting killers every
single time so yeah yeah yeah yeah it is
what it is and he's still learned he's
the first
to say dude he's just learning how to
strike now he's a great guy too
he's the man he's a dude like uh off air
and off out of the Octagon and money at
a good news having lunch of them [ __ ]
great guy so really I heard he's talking
about a tour now that's just through a
lot of people our media but you you have
to you why wouldn't you yeah do I use
them
but it is like if your contracts coming
up why wouldn't you see what your
options are
yeah that's what I heard that was this
strictly rumor so I don't know if but
yeah did that you know he has so much
time and he's such a [ __ ] young nice
chromatic funny yeah I think it just do
commentating forever and be you know
it's a very successful so he's got time
to do is he can do gay porn and I'd
watch it and beat off we went out there
then I've had so many [ __ ] tough
losses coming up in his career then it's
like you know eventually nobody flip is
bin' was gonna win that [ __ ] title
you know no yeah everybody's washed up
yeah it was over and then he you know
that's it I actually been on Bisping in
that thing oh did you oh dude you
[ __ ] made a killing hell yeah 4:52
one yeah speaking of bets go to our good
friends at bet deicide why wouldn't I
for all your bet needs go to bet these
how you use the promo code punch 25 25
and you'll get $25 betting cash that's
free money you dummies and they will
double your your deposit up to $500 it's
time to bet it's we got MBA playoffs the
second round is gonna be [ __ ] insane
UFC boxing golf is back because of
[ __ ] Tiger Woods banging people did
you bet on reality shows bet on American
Idol they're not happy think you can
spear some you bet it and it's all a bet
dsi
again the promo code is punch 25 and
they will take care of you they're our
longest-running sponsors thank you you
guys [ __ ] with them didn't you yeah
great easy-to-use interface 24/7
customer service you don't get that
anywhere else go get that dude this reid
has been the best free payout payout
good I know but you know that's another
thing you should let people know
sometimes maybe you don't but if you opt
in for the
bonus people the difference between that
this is a big thing that I tell the fans
which is important to know sure if you
want to get paid out right away don't
opt in for the bonus you still use punch
25 yeah but don't out okay bonus because
if you opt in for the bonus there's a
rollover requirement if the gamble is
here an amount of times before you get
don't opt in for the boat it's a one and
done thank you let's get out right away
if you're plenty on continuously gamble
but no should opt in for the bonus if
you want the bonus if you bonus I'm
different people get advice because I
know people complain you're back yeah
all and they're like oh they're not
they're not [ __ ] letting me get my
money out and Leichner you gotta
understand the difference so if you opt
in for that bonus not a rollover no
defense no yeah pull the curtain back a
little bit J is for do cuz he gets it
oh yeah junior to gets it to you gets it
do you bet it all are you excited yeah
sometimes I'll throw some cash down on
the fights I just get I bet with my
heart too much I see good odds and I'm
like I get skated
I don't bet the way your socks or Zach
did what's what's the biggest payout
you've had a recent because I see you
Instagram well I don't know about ever
but this year alone UFC 235 in March
that night I cashed out about 25 grand
that's nicer what is going on with you
yeah I because I usually bet all my
clothes yeah I hit a bunch of parties
one of them was a hundred dollars to win
a few grand
the other one was negative one another
to lose a few guys it's I I pick a bunch
of fighters today I'll win it caches and
how many parlays you do tend to do on a
fight a card yeah yeah it depends on the
card i'll do 2 or 3 because you know you
look sexy do you do like a lot for this
card like you bet a bunch so I put like
$10 and I pick like 10 things so let's
say let's say you pick 5 winners like
even if you're picking all people or
favorites this person will go out in the
first round
inaudible multiple bets at the exact
same time and so that you get better on
so if all three of my fighters win that
night
it's a pretty crazy payout but it's long
instead of me betting like $20 in
[ __ ] betting $20 on this one fight I
go I'm gonna bet that same $20 it I'm
gonna pick all five fights right so if
I'm wrong I lose how much did you put in
to win $25,000 I bet about a total of 2
grand worth of parlays Wow
yeah you hit them all yeah what happens
it's I missed the ones there was
multiple pause I missed I missed two of
making them but the rest of that cash
yeah I mean if you want to about if if
Mickey won I would have won about
forty-five grand Wow honey how many here
that go how many parlays did you do you
would have won more than Mickey would
have won anyone I think I had ten
parlays god damn damn Gomez do you like
what's going on with uh UFC and ESPN do
you like that now you can only get the
paper views through ESPN plus I like it
if it's being a net positive for the
fans if they do drop the price I didn't
looked at the numbers really so are they
dropping the price per pay-per-view to
where if you are no not even like five
bucks whatever they were it was
something like that
yeah if you have ESPN Plus then your
paper views are like sixty five instead
of seventy okay but it's why you're also
paying $10 a month or five dollars a
month anyway the props how's that sure
if it's cheaper for the fan it's good if
it's not cheaper for the fan I think
it's bad I think it's you're making
you're adding more barrier of entry to
what I heard was ESPN is guaranteeing
them a half a million pay-per-view buys
right guaranteed half my favor eyes no
matter what right so ESPN is banking
that the marketing of the UFC and the
marketing of ESPN coming together
they're gonna be able to probably get a
million pay per view buys every single
time hopefully in the next couple years
is he leaving yeah he quit
welcome to punch-drunk every day
somebody quits the show but oh but so I
you know the deal I think is good for
the UFC it's probably gonna end up being
good for the fighters I'm sure the
little figure out Oh some sort of bone
structure but I think they need to
consider the fans and that's they need
to just like giving back a little bit
more can't everytime be we're raising
the price we're raising the price it's
harder there's a bag it does feel like
that when I started buying UFC
pay-per-views regularly they were 39.99
yeah and they're $70 now and that's a
lot of [ __ ] money dude and there's
way more paper and it was once there was
there was one every month not now
there's what every other week yeah know
what every other my biggest thing is
that how does this help the fighters
because the UFC is going to die if they
don't get quality high-end athletes it's
gonna die and the only way they get that
is through more money like you gotta
lured people from hey I don't want to
play football I'd rather go in here and
fight and the Reebok deal really hurt
that Hydra they should not really it's
like dude stop jumping over dollars to
make dimes and and by doing that deal
with Reebok you're limiting the money
that your fighters the more if it's not
coming out of your pocket you should
allow them to make as much money as a
possibly [ __ ] can but I will say in
the defense of the UFC it's like nobody
else is doing it nobody else is creating
millionaires out of fighters nobody
there's nobody else doing and it's a
sustainable business model right so they
have guys it's a very fair business it
reminds me a comedy to a certain degree
because if you're really good you'll
probably do very well you'll probably
make a lot of money
you'll probably and even if you're not
even that good just getting into the UFC
and you're if you're good enough to just
get in the UFC
you could probably own the gym you could
parlay that into other things yeah you
almost like owning a gym for them is
like having a successful podcast yeah
it's just sort of like you can make
money doing other things in that realm
it's sort of a fair business and you
have guys like Conor who are coming in
and they're opening the window wider and
wider guys are getting paid a hell of a
lot more now than they were five years
ago
and it's gonna continue to go but I
won't say like I gotta give the UFC
credit because they are very
smart and they've navigated this entire
crazy world with legal in 50 states now
it went from being the most barbaric
thing in the entire world and they turn
it into a [ __ ] multi-billion dollar
corporation in very very mention
mainstream sponsors so you can sit here
on our [ __ ] you know you know talking
[ __ ] like we know I just sort of put
some faith we get here lunch every woman
in the room everyone yeah there'll be a
better sport my opinion I think female
MMA is big because it never would able
to piggyback on to the male sports and
that's the female riding is just you
it's it's very easy I mean airports
Latinas versus black chicks over phones
fun it's fun to watch and it also
doesn't feel watered-down when a woman's
doing it like I totally agree I totally
agree sometimes it does but the WNBA
it's like I feel like the male division
or all of the the male side is more
watered-down than females are hungry or
the chicks are so hungry right now and
their skill level is catching up so it's
like they're they're probably 5 10 years
behind in terms of evolution of these
fighters and yeah you know everyone's
gonna look like [ __ ] cyborgs in 10
years every check is gonna be a [ __ ]
monster it's gonna be you know [ __ ]
we're just all muscles it's gonna be
crazy
FEMA MMA here's the thing we all when we
were kids or anybody listen to the show
you know anybody who's in a generation
that uses the internet we watch those
[ __ ] fight videos dude we watch chick
fights we watch dude fight so we don't
discriminate a fight as a [ __ ] babies
and if good fight we're gonna [ __ ]
click on it and I think that's why it
works with ya guys a watch of the moment
Ronda Rousey got kicked in the face by
Holly Holm and her legs got wobbly that
that female MMA changed yes because she
was so dominant and it was like no one
can beat her once they caught up to her
[ __ ] arm bar which no one could
figure out once she got clipped Alice
said you like well there's a lot of
people that are coming out right now you
need the story you need to be able to go
back and forth you need to be able to go
who's gonna win yeah those white
amateurs Johnson was never able to
really sell tickets and nobody really
gave a [ __ ] he was so dominant so
underrated
my team and it wasn't even a dominance
that like Anderson Silvia dominant or
it's like one two three punch it's over
like you came to see that yeah it wasn't
exciting the same way it's also it's
hard I think for the average UFC friend
we is 195 [ __ ] pounds and they're
watching these very small guys it's a
it's a you know unless there's a crazy
story there I think much of a good match
abut yeah well they need bonus a story I
mean the matchups they need they need
you know the highlight reels to sell
these crazy epic fights and they don't
have guys 125 pounds that are people
really give a [ __ ] about it was yeah
difficult to kind of get traction for
with Anderson coming in and you know
beating people the way he did Rich
Franklin was his dominant champion he
broke his [ __ ] nose off his face it
was it's easy to kind of get into that
story you know I'm saying there's
beautiful violence isn't he fighting
again like very funny
no Anderson's like on the next card I
think yeah he fought that style breaker
or whatever now I loved I loved it Sonya
yeah he might be my favorite fighter
right now he's a killer he's funny and
he's humble and he's but he's like
entertaining I want to hate because
every time somebody's supposed to be the
next coming of Jesus I like to pick
against him I like to go yeah Connors
gonna lose it I pick Marcus bridge
against Conor McGregor's debut come on
Marcus you got a better boy all the time
because I I wanna I want to be right
there's something about like you know
yeah how about just being like oh I'm
the one you don't want to be told who's
great you want to be the finding it out
cuz they're not gonna remember me pinky
against me they're gonna one time where
I [ __ ] pick that guy to beat him you
get to go I [ __ ] told you suck at
that moment I think that's what happens
every time and I have to just let myself
go and say no no style bender's he's
above and beyond to everybody else it
seems to be but he's humble too yeah
well I mean he seems it yes no he's
respectful to his opponents he's funny
in a press conference a con
John Jones are you like he's so good but
he just can't get out of his own way is
he so good because he was doing that
[ __ ] it would he be that good if he
wasn't doing that [ __ ] are they are they
bending the rules to make John Jones
still be able to fight no for sure I
think so I think that you know John's a
huge star they do watch it happen with
Connors
they just if you're that big of a star
it's just a different game you're
playing behind the scenes and where
there's smoke there's fire the you know
the there's not a debate here there's
some shady [ __ ] going on he obviously
was using some [ __ ] steroids multiple
times yeah and you know it's we taught
me a [ __ ] been talking about this ad
nauseam but it's like the guy dropper
the guys that need to do to do that
there's something psychological there so
I don't know but I think that he
probably wouldn't believe him in himself
enough to get that good about that
totally he was alleged totally here so
whether the juice was enough to put he
might be good enough without it but
psychologically you sort of beat
yourself some time like very bonds right
now what percentage has Bisbing ever
told you he thinks people are using
steroids out of Fighters I've heard not
more than 90 more to have 90% they think
yeah that's what the Diaz brothers said
a while ago they were like wow
everybody's on steroids dude so why not
just source it news fine III said so
I'll go they should they should just
make what I want to do if I had if I was
a Multi multi like you $5 yeah you've
gotta be stationed that's all drugs you
have to pay super heavy with super
heavyweight we don't test we are
offshore we are [ __ ] in Indian
reservations we're overseas to 65,000
mean to 65 and above these are monsters
yeah it's MMA with [ __ ] absolute
monsters it would be such a huge Mar and
it eat lot because it's out of you've
seen it's above 265 always the debate of
like all [ __ ] how would these guys do
could John Jones go up to 275 feet
against the [ __ ] monsters of this
thing it would be such a [ __ ] great
thing I would just do it I and I
wouldn't care if everybody came in and
signed the contract and said hey yeah we
get steroids who cares yeah it's an even
playing field I don't really give a [ __ ]
English yeah exactly it was it was you
know yeah it just has to be even you
can't have guys coming in and you know
playing the game fair but if I choose to
come in not using it that's my choice
you deserve death you're about to get
it's like I can as a comic I can choose
to use writers I choose not to
because I can write myself but nobody
really chooses to use writers is that
even a thing that anybody really does on
a high high level I'm sure Chris Rock
very famous oh yeah not gonna stand up
though just for his monologue things and
all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] I've heard as well that he uses
writers will I know that for a fact that
he does when I I know when he was doing
like the Oscars and [ __ ] because they
would all come in and let me ask you a
question a writer - no but is does he
use a writer in this capacity way
because if I was as famous as Chris Rock
and I was putting out that high level of
[ __ ] is it against the rules to hire
Nate bargatze Michelle wolf whoever else
you know is written for him sit down in
a room and say hey these are my ideas
let's [ __ ] throw ideas back and forth
this is what comics did in the beginning
this how everyone started how difference
is the [ __ ] the billionaire so we can
pay them a lot of money I don't believe
I truly don't believe that Chris Rock
says cool great joke pushed and goes on
say judges doesn't I just don't believe
that he's too much of a master like he
said III agree well he does he probably
pays really high level skilled people to
challenge him to think differently that
he normally thinks and I think that I
have no problem I have no problem with
that at all I think for writers but
that's not really I don't think that's
an issue I think that you're looking to
create the absolute highest quality
special possible scene are you do that
with his friends where he's like has
these jokes he's like Dave did exactly
that I would my special Tim and Zak both
Mike Kent or are just great writers big
Jay as well I said dude listen to my
special if you see any other angles
things that Ollie out it of course
because you know you have friends I
didn't pay them cuz I'm not rich but the
difference would be if I paid them and
then gave them credit I mean there are
people writing right now they're not
it's what any comic in the world does
when the one does have a be a
millionaire one just happens you can
afford to pay his friend it's a lot of
money to do though you can afford any
louis c.k ground response as well you
know who could afford to pay their
friends to write hey I won't $50,000
under last year's dude I'll be right
now when I when I came back home from
that it was my I came home on my dad's
birthday I gave him 10 grand for his
birthday
well you know punch in the face the
month before the month before was my
birthday gave me 500 bucks that's what I
gave him 10 grand that's great well you
know maybe $500 is like the most I've
ever gotten from my birthday that's
right dude that's great dude that's
great and then you bet it all you did
you use that 500 to make the 25 grand I
put it towards it yeah great if anyone
wants to subscribe to my place
Gabe Killian MMA on Twitter how about
your auntie give out clue and tips on
patreon I have an email service of
people subscribed to my place I follow
this guy on patreon he says through
numbers he can tell you who's gonna win
through like let's call gum a trio like
numerology like yeah he says it's like
what do you mean see how often are you
winning are you if you were to go and
track everything you've ever been are
you like way up yeah every year I'd say
70% dish so you sell you sell tips or
you sell what you're gonna bet then you
use that money to bet I mean not really
but yeah or a lot of people buying
you're really Gabe the banker bro okay
well maybe put you on Bisping's podcast
and we'll do a segment or something with
you you got to give us some good picks
again with me some money respect and
I'll show improved that I'd bet on them
against I love that yeah
do you do you take photos of all of your
things and just save him not all of them
but uh often and I used to I strive for
a website I when I give my plays out for
free some of them are on the websites
doing like the biz being play cool I
gave that our public that recommended
people to bet on what website was that
I'm in the arts breaker calm uh-huh and
you're not writing for them anymore cuz
I know you did that for a long time I'm
technically I could still log in write
an article but I've been I haven't in
over years I've been busy and stuff kind
of money yeah I also started a fried
chicken restaurant in North Hollywood
a pop-up fried chicken it is good I'm
not gonna lie it's [ __ ] good
no but we're gonna go there after this
and they did a stand-up they did a
stand-up show there and like you got
paid in chicken and it was worth it yeah
man we're open at nights 8:00 p.m. till
sellout at in North Hollywood to sell
out
yeah raging hot J we own this place yeah
don't you dress better what is going on
with this I just feel like he's way more
successful than he got the grody [ __ ]
son by the way I thank you thank you
Chicago Cubs for this Brody shirt hello
that's very cool stood another baseball
team did something the Yankees what's up
with Brody I think he'll be here later
yeah because well Brody's room his
connection dude with the Yankees and the
Cubs his college teammate and I even
believe roommate for a while was the
pitching coach for the Yankees and then
the Cubs so that's how he was like
affiliated with both of him good buddy
was there see ya Yankees did a thing on
their scoreboard and so did the Cubs
Aaron we all wanted to be Triple E Aaron
how is that for talking baseball
everyone prayed that'll be Triple E
actually he bet out of parlay that he
caught he cost me like 10 grand Gomez
who you gonna fight next I keep calling
me out I'm all dude I'm [ __ ] old man
I want to here's the thing there was a
there's talk with me fighting Jimmy
Martinez who's a big but you're doing it
again
I wanna because I want to get in shape
again I can't motivate to get in shape
George Perez would be a fun you just got
into a [ __ ] three rounder with this
idiot yeah but I barely broke a sweat on
that one no I mean I want to do it again
I think it was fun I want to fight she
wants let's go oh I bet you let's go you
and Gabe would do a fight yeah that
would be a great fight he launches far
oh yeah bet she pays I got some yeah
I've seen you really mad multiple times
in my life and I and I every wasn't
anybody warned me by the way I think I
dream like
I tried it one of my friends like dude
she's [ __ ] dangerous so just you know
a couple people did but I'm pretty
positive I did a little here's the day
before she's like I'm gonna [ __ ] suck
him sad way whatever you say hold on I
got to muck it up with go I'm gonna muck
his brains out it's Road yeah I want I
want it what Olivia rolled out I haven't
called anybody anybody Ari please Ari
wouldn't find Ari will not do it you
won't do it won't fight me I dumped a
matter at skank fast like a [ __ ] after I
was sick for a week look I would do with
Jimmy you know but it's Jimmy who
Shubert achieve Martinez Jimmy Carr how
big is that he's huge he's like six five
big black guy 250 the challenge is great
but our neighbors would think of
actually around the same size now we're
not twice your neighbor size yeah yeah
well you're way bigger yeah does he know
how to do Watchers South Central or
something he like he's no [ __ ] [ __ ]
that I mean that's like let me tell you
this is what I learned okay when you go
and train with people who really not a
fight right now all that Street [ __ ]
doesn't mean [ __ ] if you're what if
you're down to fight if look if we're in
a street fight that Street shouldn't
mean something because you're gonna be
willing to throw right if we're meeting
in the center of a [ __ ] cage or a
ring yeah I'm fighting if it's not like
any of these we're both willing we're
both of us so then it becomes like well
how much the street fighting really mean
in an MMA fight right and it doesn't
really nothing much [ __ ] doesn't mean
much at all he'd have to in his athletic
enough that I'm not an athlete at all
but I learned I thought give me black
yeah he's got extra bone in his foot so
I figured he could probably
no he could Road what he he's a very
athletic I've seen do back flips and
[ __ ] yeah he could more than likely if
he got into really committed to it get
into an MMA camp and train his body to
do enough to beat somebody might has he
yeah
has he woody I'm obsessed so I would
train twice a day like I in what I
thought Ryan O'Neal I found out Ryan
didn't train MMA he didn't train jujitsu
if I in my mind I was fighting somebody
who's training like a [ __ ] MMA
fighter and training like wrestling
non-stop so I obsess over it so in my
mind it's not even about the physical
side it's not even about a fight it's
more about goal-setting ending q is
Jamar neighbors or whoever are they
enough to stand in the way of me setting
this goal which is just to physically
overtake them and this thing right if it
was basketball or football or anything
else it's just a physical activity
that's all it is
take out being afraid of being punched
in the face take out the you know the
fear of fighting it's just a physical
activity so is that that much of a goal
tomorrow neighbours is he the athlete
with that so instrumental I got a name
for you hey Fletcher
Bret Bret Ernst would that be an
interesting fight I think yeah he beats
her it's no problem really I did I can't
really fight but I think I can set a
goal and I could get into an MMA I think
Bret light you used to love the fight
was there any time in your fight with
Ryan O'Neal especially like when cuz you
were got a you pretty much had him down
on his back you were like it's like full
guard where you're like I think I'm
gonna kiss this [ __ ] right now
kiss him in the mouth yeah I loved when
you uh got mad at me on [ __ ] the
internet for no [ __ ] reason
ya know I look everyone had to pick
their teams and pick their sides these
[ __ ]
is easy they are all [ __ ] my friends
are rooting against me I'm listening to
them [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna get my ass
beat it's okay babe I went on the stage
and I wiped [ __ ] Ryan O'Neal's blood
on their face but I like when she was
running around we did it we did how do
you think I got that job snap yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's got to fight somebody
sooner you're gonna really get it's
coming here I would I would do it he and
Triple E would you fight somebody what
depends on who it is man I'm like I
don't want to fight a guy who's way
younger than me I'd fight a woman I baby
won't fight me I'll fight I want a baby
so bad does not a have a baby but to
fight one but none of these babies are
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] online want a piece
of me yeah I fight I fight I do the
thrill of walking out nice rental in
rush yeah
it was not it was such a cool experience
you know uh you know Alice is [ __ ] he
does a really cool thing there I really
love I'm doing the next one but it's Pro
Wrestling we're doing oh that's right
you are doing that I love it we're doing
pressing escape us so are you guys yeah
are you guys good two miles maybe is May
4th yeah I don't even hear about this I
don't know you're gonna be in a small
private one ah but you're gonna like
practice it for like we've already on my
stage my wrestler name is Armageddon
okay god I was gonna say give us five
guesses before you tell us my arm Oh get
your first guess know what would have
been your first gay a [ __ ] on a second
yeah yeah come dumpster would be one of
them come dumpster know it's gonna be
great dude I'm super excited dancers
with [ __ ] that's another one I would
go the Brooklyn cops lover hot slobber
no everything's gotta be like okay why
can't it be papa
you know positive HIV positive yeah it's
fun dude it's fun yeah I uh I think any
guy you know there's something you know
you sort of learn about yourself getting
into a [ __ ] fight sure I'm doing it
that way in particular where your
training your figuring out like you
really just testing yourself because
it's none of it about him I had no idea
that's other you do a fight you start to
realize you have no [ __ ] clue enough
fighters there's no tape there's none of
that [ __ ] you can't get you there's
no it's about challenging yourself to
get yourself as good as possible and
make yourself absolutely I paired for
any situation it's about you it's now
you know once guys are at a high level
and you could watch tape on each other
you could set up a real game plan and
but what me and Ryan we could talk all
the [ __ ] everyone talked all that [ __ ]
we you know me and I'm he had no clue I
had no clue you know and you don't
really know that until you really get
there and you know me and we found out
the most interesting like when you fight
in those the anticipation of getting hit
is almost worse than the actual hit
because your Adrenaline's going he knows
that you know and it's just like what's
worse then what the anticipation of
getting taught a lesson or just [ __ ]
getting what's coming to you but the
anticipation I'm like that's not that
bad you're like little [ __ ] here comes
again and you start like panicking on
that on there which is a patient the hit
than the actual head I feel like once
you've had that first hit you're like
[ __ ] I'm already here is just cracked on
yeah yeah it's like jumping into a pool
when it's called you I could already in
the water so are you so funny cuz I was
like no I want five rounds five minutes
each I'm like re you have no clue what
you're asking for because well Ari tries
doesn't he [ __ ] me on this because we
do these bag of bets and Ari is smart he
knows how to manipulate it so you'll
you'll [ __ ] blow out and he'll win
yeah and we did that with bowling I
supposed to go beat him for three we did
that with the 40 [ __ ] weed ran a
40-yard dash that's what it was
yeah and I went the first one we had
timed it I won by like you know maybe
half a second or something at all times
we're close but I want okay now we're
gonna do it again and then now we're all
gonna do it at the same time until he
finally won one and I'm like we had to
run the 40-yard dash four times and then
Ari wins the on the fourth one oh I told
you I was better than you idiots you're
all stupid hey Luz Gomez have you ever
made bets before
what do you mean like I bet ya
we did the back of us with re-remember
yes where do you pay those off
I mean I would pay it off pretty quickly
Jason knows like two years of bets what
does he know
ah three of them what are they what are
they right now I'm in the mall tell us
about them well dress like a [ __ ] he
won't do that why because it's easy I'm
not worried about it at all it was easy
you would have paid it off fine well two
times you were to pay off Johnny oh no
I'm gonna love it it's 2019 guys trans
I'll make money and it would be a new
lifestyle change I'm fine with that I
think you should be you dude
I'm gonna wear a shot at shock collar
yeah your entire episode you won't do
that all we got to do is get it like
that's it okay bring it you have one can
you bring it next week bring it to the
store when I'm back are you I have one
day what's that are you in town Sunday I
know I'm leaving on the 29th that's
that's a Monday where are you going
Sunday brick give me the got collar I'll
come grab where are you going
Canada oh that's right he's doing his
gigs and then you all um so it's a real
simple one that one they don't want me
to do who they Allah no me to say is
they are here yeah yeah Mike verdolino
okay go go bring them in go ask him
don't bring my doesn't want you to do
because God bring you back on their
YouTube go bring it in
you're not gonna be showing anything
you're not gonna be doing anything what
a job I have to jerk off on YouTube to
live during this show so I don't show up
here he just has to be on skype beating
Otto there's a whole entire shell that's
all right he won't do it and he acts
like there's this like this thing going
on
no I'm not I mean I'll do it you just
pay them all off on the same time yeah
that that's a great idea
yeah just have one really awful episode
for you and then get it over with
I'm not worried about any of it and then
why haven't you paid them just I mean
for a bunch of reasons multi- do you
really want to get into who's paid off
what bet I paid off every bet on one bet
okay all right we've all agreed on I
love around t-shirt I think I paid it
off
you referenced I did it I did it that
this is what the Oh half okay that's
that's the same thing of him not beating
let me put the [ __ ] shock collar on
his balls he [ __ ] manipulated but I
still plan to annihilate it yeah you did
how did I meant that the other time
because it was either neck or balls and
I chose balls you cried I go neck now
okay that's so stupid yeah absolutely
ah Rios 2 uo 3 i'll 0 so did you tell
Johnny or did you not tell Johnny call
Johnny did you not tell him that we
needed a fart funnel you exhale no make
that you're making [ __ ] off I swear to
god Johnny [ __ ] your liking [ __ ] on my
life making [ __ ] I'm gonna talk louder
doesn't make it right doesn't make it
right
going back and [ __ ] making [ __ ] off
Charlie said them all long Johnny like
Ronnie Colin I don't give a [ __ ] am I
making it all up
you're making it up Johnny or did you
not I sucked the part you made it up
that's a great audio bit ok there no not
OK hang it on OK your [ __ ] mate ok
Gough I will do my know you keep saying
that and you keep pushing it off you all
we can't do more bag of bets because
you're not paying him off up I'll do it
I'm fine with it I'm fine with it I've
heard that before
loose Gomez is quitting the show we now
had a fourth guy quit the show you're
making [ __ ] up he's locked out seems
like everything's going well for you
yeah dude it's been fun
how does your taping go really good yeah
would you do have and when is that aired
are they don't know yeah I think in like
five months yep
but yeah it was fun San Antonio was San
Antonio and oh that's weird because
they're Mexicans and you're different
kind of speck right yes so how'd that go
yeah you're spicier I ended my set with
Puerto Ricans are better so and have a
go boom it was fun
was really really good they came how
stoked today for that wall getting built
yeah they're building it right what
jokes you do they ought to be Ladd is it
me or did Latinos like it could they be
like how Brown was just set my [ __ ] was
like everybody else seemed pretty Latino
and I was like hey yo like I came out
very white oh yeah you're the whitest of
the Browns yeah don't you hate it when
you're [ __ ] sweet tee' speak Spanish
at all a little bit yeah cuz everybody's
now trying to do ours in Spanish I know
that Tom Segura is working on that
rainout doing an hour in Spanish no he's
not speaks fluent really speaks fluent
yeah Tom no this is Latin
he's totally Latin and he speaks fluent
Spanish I don't speak fluent but I can
trick in I didn't know that that's crazy
so hey well I'm glad he's doing that cuz
I was worried about him making money I
think like XG I think Jorge Perez
I think Alou Tom Segura here you want
unlock it and then hey sis Trejo are all
doing an hour in Spanish oh hell yeah I
would never be able to do an hour in
Spanish they're probably all doing 15 my
friend Santi Espinosa in New York is
producing a Spanish shows now dude dude
look at the way you I mean like you guys
don't live in California but like you
drive like north you'll see just giant
billboards for mariachi bands you've
never heard of yeah playing giant
[ __ ] arena yeah five thousand satyrs
huge market if you could tap into it how
I am I need to learn smell my buddy
senior guacamole is doing a whole hour
and number one he's kind of like
guacamole
he's like the carrot top of [ __ ] yes
that's a real person wetbacks no I went
back but that's how bad comedy is it
made you think I honestly seen your
guacamole
I can't he gets up on Monday at Monday
nights at the store probably does it
probably is remember we had a UH what
was the name of your character Oh sticky
fingers Gonzalez so it was based on
Carlos Mencia right and he would go up
full-on like sombrero [ __ ] everything
and now going after like two or three
comics and I would just steal all my
whole act was everything the last three
comics did they just he literally write
them yeah bringing a naughty show back
we're doing it Donn said I hope we
should so stick your fingers in it yeah
I think that'd be great we're gonna do
downtown this promoter wants to promote
I'll do any show as long as I don't have
to [ __ ] promote I'll give you a top
show don't introduce me and you'd be
like dude don't all you every time
you're on this show you steal people's
act dog I wrote it all this stuff with
my brain today this is stuff I just
wrote it today and it would just be
everything run as easy just did you know
so what's going on with our legion of
skanks everybody looks like they're
killing it yeah how's the show going
how's the news studio I hear it's
beautiful it's great yeah studios nice
is there any truth there's glory holes
in the bathroom ah yeah hundred percent
that's really we make all of our female
producers ha hello strangers before they
can even get on Steph are you guys
hiring yeah dude yeah you guys are
[ __ ] crazy look at this place you
guys are [ __ ] yea kidding there's a
brand new camper out there if anybody
needs a place to stay here's a little
weird how long is the ATC been around
Aaron five years five beers
Aaron spot how's it going with the wife
we always ask you every week that's not
what she's telling us she's telling us
it's not going good you heard the same
thing right there yeah the chat boys
yeah he's married why didn't get marry
she wants get married so badly and of
course that's what they do that's why
they call them dream kill let's get
America right now live on the show oh my
god they'll be champion marry people I
am I'm a Church of Satan yeah so what
about RVs are you getting closer the guy
who said he would never do anything with
the show
I'll never live with another woman again
yeah they're terrible and they're messy
and now like Adam yeah he is huh yeah is
there anyone is there anyone who has
been a better career than Ari like in
terms of just just he does what he wants
to do he does a podcast we have the ice
penis travels the world is she gonna be
cool when he goes on his weird like
[ __ ] tours in the [ __ ] Far East
yeah I don't know I mean she he cheats
on a record early so whoa whoa whoa
breaking news breaking news Ari ari Ari
clearly cheats 100 I will not be a part
of that sent from watching flicking the
bean yelling out moves yeah just mucking
away she's mucking herself in the corner
watching re cheat and lie so he's
already still grinding you all the time
no he always gives you [ __ ] when I see
him no Aria sorry's afraid of me in real
life he just talked [ __ ] on social media
yeah and you threw your night balls he
threw urine and me on this show me
remember when he peed in that Cup and
then then he drank it he actually drank
it I know me about 20 years ago I know
we on skank fest last year I I peed in a
cup and I doubt a minute it's I recall
yeah that's great any time all right now
he's gonna he's gonna up it and we I
don't I don't need him to [ __ ] poop
in the cup yeah I just feel like the
lucky thing was his poop is gonna move
so much slower like I'll be able to get
to come cannon what are you gonna go
[ __ ] mean tricks he just died yeah
well I told the buter said that's what I
was gonna do because we were getting
into it last year and he just kept on
challenging me over and over again so I
was gonna just I was gonna film a
documentary of this this is really true
all my employees vouched for this
because I was gonna make them do it
documented was gonna be me the rats
confessed weekend jerking off into
things and then getting my employees to
get all ready to eat them and drink them
to rent them with that the whole weekend
but he's now yeah I'm knowing it then
documenting it the whole weekend and
then premiering it on the last day of
the festival the documentary
they'll do that you should stop talking
about what a building it I know but I
die often not to and I tried to tell Ari
I was like do this well then I was a
dude look I didn't do that so can't we
just call it even now and then he's like
if you don't think you're if you don't
think gonna get my piss piss on you
you're crazy it's gonna happen at your
fear fest yeah it's gonna happen somehow
I'm trying I'm trying to figure it out
I'm trying to is there ever gonna is the
war ever gonna come to me at the 8th all
things comedy festival that's what
Stanhope pissed on arias okay he's got a
real [ __ ] rap I know it's weird
I hate have you ever been peed on no I
have it the day's young no it's early in
the day peed on is wonderful yeah you've
got how you never been you've been peed
on you just don't know have you ever
taken the shower with a guy literally
everyone's just pissing on each other
that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] you're in
hilarious you guys you guys aren't the
ability to piss on each other you just
peed on your legs just I'm pissing on
their own side question what percentage
of famous female comics have writers for
them would you say write don't know what
writers further stand up for like like
Road stand up like just a general stand
up stand up I mean I've been doing
stand-up for a long time I don't really
see it happen as often as you know this
is not a big issue in the world of
comedy triple he's leaving he's quitting
now it happens sometimes that happens
yeah triple e I'll hire you to write for
me if you want yeah I mean the whole the
whole idea of like I don't really know
people that are getting hired to write
for people like that where they're just
ghost writing the material I don't know
yeah that's a good point I literally
haven't seen it that's a good point
I assume you're saying there I don't
know you hear the rumors that like so
all these people I was right I just know
celebrate writers writers will talk [ __ ]
so I feel like I would have heard about
these people who are ghosts writing
other people's that are you
but you know you've never written stand
up for somebody bring me those panel
jokes rose panel jokes it's a little
different I've lived worse battle jokes
for people to battle still going or as
they hit its peak going it's still going
how's that in New York how's it in the
New York version rose battle going on
through it anymore for a long time yeah
I did it for a while roastmaster self
komedy Fight Club it's cool they get
there great show they have the best
battlers in New York right but I was
just I was too busy dude I can't [ __ ]
work on somebody else's brand it's not
my show I do a say so for me to expend
any effort or energy doing some like
that it's hard enough to promote your
own [ __ ] let alone no I got no nose you
dress battle each other on the show
why don't you versus Triple E Rus battle
we don't want to promote other people's
brands how's the gang over at the show
David [ __ ] Jay I heard he's doing a
whole herd he's doing a whole hour in
Spanish just like everybody else
grande what's your favorite city do
stand-up it good question what's yours
Tampa's a [ __ ] great well it's really
tacoma's great depending on what you're
asking what's best Crowder was just the
best city to go and hang after the show
that's best shows your tap is pretty
great Boston's incredible Chicago's
great Boston stupid Chicago's great yeah
anywhere is like blue-collar [ __ ]
people yeah I agree
la sucks now New York City's most fun
too good people are [ __ ] [ __ ] in
all these cities now everyone feels
everybody's jaded
so that they're jaded there yeah you get
to see a [ __ ] thousand dollar ticket
Comedy Festival every night yeah but I
mean that's a $500 that's a Comedy
Festival it's a $500 ticket for
virtually free but how many can you so
[ __ ] about how many people are going
cuz they give a [ __ ] about Santa but how
many people are going because that's
entertainment those are monkeys on stage
to entertain their famous between dinner
and drinks I think it's I think it's a
lot more of that like there's somebody
on that line up whether it's Rogen or
Joey Diaz or whoever's on there that you
are a die-hard fan
their podcast and their whatever I think
everybody everything else is secondary
that's here between New York though like
New York nobody goes to comedy shows
because there's somebody famous in the
lineup nobody that's I think that's 80%
of why they go in LA yeah dude this town
is really in [ __ ] dude
it's like crystal iya iya Rogan Joey
Diaz and that's the only one selling a
lot of tickets now yeah and if you don't
have them on the show it's gonna be hard
to fill a room man yeah we just ganks
filled it up last time without any of
those guys so suck my [ __ ] dick it's
like and then like a lot of people do
great I put down killer shows but that's
hard to sell a dollar I get Segura and
Christina do two bucks yeah but you you
need like but bras for sure Chrysler for
sure but like all of those like and a
theof on maybe like all of those equal
one Joe Rogan guess what they all come
and they're all podcast people and
they're all podcasts national headliners
their global headliner TV doesn't fill
rooms of course podcast fill room yep
you're totally right yeah probably right
you're totally right and it's like
that's what I'm saying is like there's
somebody that's a die-hard fan of Marc
Maron's podcast or Rogen's podcast or
whatever and they'll go and buy that
ticket everybody else it's awesome I did
Morgan's podcast a few weeks ago it'll
come out to come out to a show in Philly
that just saw me on that show looked me
up and they're like yeah I just wanna
see comments to do Rogen's Marc it's
amazing it's pretty crazy it's amazing I
think he was somebody was telling me the
other day that he they were trying to
get him to do Fallon he's like I have no
desire to do that yeah Joe that's funny
any of them no desire to really do that
but you found your pocket yeah basically
that's it because the thing is he gets
five times the numbers that the tonight
show gets doesn't know oh dude not five
times but he does better night show
probably probably close to I absolutely
whatever his numbers I feel like 1015
million downloads in episode or whatever
night show gets baby 10 million no no
they don't keep that many viewers oh no
no no they get maybe three to the three
mil yep Brogan gets that it's not a
little more time all right
I heard working is substantially more
than that yeah don't we know the way
podcast yeah right we know the ratios
right yeah so if he's getting a million
on YouTube I'm telling you he's getting
like [ __ ] yeah you know way more than
230 X that's not the important number
yes tonight up on The Tonight Show
nobody gives a [ __ ] no and you do rogas
podcast as a comic it's better to do
Rogen's podcast for two and a half hours
than it is to do five minutes on on
Fallon and burn material how many people
watch family I don't look at this right
now look it up I'm looking right Johnny
let's look that up we'll be right back
after this break point six million
vultures told you that's it old you look
a dick tonight's show it's over Logan
gets twice that doggie skanks doesn't
get that many but were you know it's not
that crazy that we could get there
that's not crazy at all
no that's not crazy at all no that's it
2.6 million viewers that's the gold
standard of our entire lives The Tonight
Show that's bananas
that's [ __ ] bananas network gets
better numbers than that I thought they
would get like 810 million viewers I
thought it was like a prime time like
you sit back you know to be first why do
you think Conan does it a [ __ ]
podcast now yeah does he I didn't even
know those yeah do you show when to a
half an hour go to me our news calm me
take blue chew me get rock hard
[Laughter]
the best podcast I would listen to all
the time so we did in Nashville Comedy
Festival myself Eddie Bravo
we followed Janeane Garofalo okay Ginny
Gras
we're in the we're in Sherri Shepherd
just runs a life like nobody xel-há
black female comic runs the life I think
by the way so so the shows going late
and we were sitting in Jeanine comes out
and by the way wonderful comic are you
serious for job-ready bombing at
festivals I really so nice to because
she's a stream of consciousness she's
really nice consciousness yeah so she
gets off we started talking and then her
and Eddie Bravo started interacting and
it was the most gold [ __ ] you'll ever
see how Eddie's over here they don't
understand we're here she's she's using
a rubber guard yeah it's like a puppies
he's a cat for the first time and a cat
sees a puppy for the first time what are
you yeah it was [ __ ] your name I could
listen them talk all the time oh I bet
that was a real meeting of the minds
those two girls like they do she doesn't
have any internet I heard you say
possible to get a holder she'll give you
her number
that's how really sell off the internet
she is yeah cuz she came out like she
always goes on a limb like she during
the early 2000 she's anti-war cost her
her her TV show and then she came out
from Louie gonna know Lucy K she went
stuck up for him and she got pounded on
for that dude it is just a cheap way for
me to say the n-word but I was watching
I was watching Jerry Shepard the loot
the louis ck's old shell which you know
got jack but there was so many funny
bits in there but he was lucky Louie
yeah yeah yeah hit lucky Louie CK and he
was at this art gallery in New York like
real pretentious and hated it and was so
uncomfortable and it was just this one
big room there was all white and in the
middle of the room was just this buzzer
right and he's like oh the packed place
and he walks in and just hits the buzzer
and it just goes really loud everybody
in the thing turned and looked at him
like it was him that you [ __ ] bit
I was so funny that be I don't know
maybe think about that other than my
wanting missing the words me the story
and we'll be right back after this break
I saw top that's been our show
thank you for tuning in Congrats why
look for you on HBO
Latino want to find Kim should be
mucking it up at the back of a bar
somewhere if anybody wants a mop monkey
you're the [ __ ] spoken like a true
boyfriend what airport we got to be
fighting at soon lax same thing I said
before just follow me on Twitter it can
really cognate Instagram at Kim Condon
I'll put all my dates up there go go
check out the other Pods legion of
skanks real last podcast and believe you
me with Michael Bisping all available
gases general Network calm all the live
streams are frayed go there and just you
know gotta log in or anything anytime
the show is streaming you can go and
just watch it and it's getting faster
everybody's excited - best would be
great come home punch once their punch
trunks there it's an entire [ __ ]
party for a whole weekend it's a blast
from noon to 2:00 a.m. for three full
days that we just party if you want a
party and you want it the shows are
obviously great with 150 comedians 20
live podcast and specialty shows
undoubtably the best lineup in the world
I don't need to sell this [ __ ] it's sold
out already but go get free tickets my
following Infini CBD and if you come
you're gonna see don't miss next year
get the tickets early cuz Mel out very
early I haven't heard back yet am I in
we're doing their submissions now
respect kill him what you got Gabe
Killian MMA on Twitter subscribe to my
plays the money right Fight Club make
some paper player make some paper get
paint guys got a bet to you say I use a
hook punch 25 and always see geek use
the code punch drunk and consider it
sucked Thanks